You
Can you help me
I
Have you all the um
yeah yeah yeah don't scare me
oh
fuck
I'm jealous
here we go I got it
excellent yeah I can read chat now
I can read chat
properly this time
I wish you could make like text a little bigger
cause I'm a bit blonde
it's so hard to read all your muscles
I'm so blonde
alright
I'm a little too late
how are you doing on this fine evening mama so I'm doing
I'm doing alright I have a lot of energy
I'm a lot of energy
not I don't really know what to do with it
I hope you don't mind a little chatting before we play
a place for a bit then
oh let me
I forgot
oh
um you didn't hear that
what
what are you doing here
I'm a little too late
alright
why
I'm wondering how much I'm going to be
I was setting up
stuff for today. I added the merch thingies on there. You see that? On there. Look at that. Right there.
I added the merch and I added alerts and a bunch of new things. It was really hard trying to set it all up.
So I'm glad it went okay.
Um, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
As I believe I am not. So I'm 20, 30. What is called your book?
Or if my bullies wrote in that. I never amount to anything.
Your amount to so much more. Do not believe your bullies. They mean nothing.
Alright, you are everything and you are what?
I already want you to be.
You are great. You are amazing.
And you're all good boys and good girls.
Oops. Yeah, yeah.
Come on. Are you okay? I'm okay. Just a lot of energy. A lot, a lot, a lot of energy. I'm sorry.
I'm having like a bit of issue on Twitter at the moment where people are sending me art or um, they're putting the tag in their art and stuff.
Unfortunately, when I click on the tags, a lot of the art and um, memes and stuff that you guys sent me, some of it do not appear in there.
So I'm really sorry if I missed some of your art and stuff.
I'm really sorry. I'm so sorry.
So I do get some of your stuff, but I have to like literally be sent some stuff that get unseen.
So Twitter has hit you with anything or you know, they're probably not letting you, your hashtags get seen.
Unfortunately, Twitter, Twitter being Twitter, yeah, yeah, yeah. I agree.
Sorry, I do not take DMs. They have no clothes.
I know that's what the hashtags are for, but don't worry.
We'll sort it itself out, I'm sure. We'll sort it itself out.
It helps for people to comment under posts with the tags, weird Twitter thing. I didn't know that.
Maybe it does. I know when some people comment, that's how I end up seeing some of the posts.
Um, so I end up seeing it only because someone else responded or retweeted that, so I end up seeing it.
Oh, that's me! Understand.
Yeah, it seems a bit ginky today. Very ginky.
Here you go, yo, yo, yo.
Don't let Michael Kong go.
Those eyes are very hypnotic, are they?
Have you eaten today, Azu? Have I eaten today?
Yeah, yeah, no, I haven't eaten.
I'll eat, I promise, I promise, I promise.
I promise, I promise, I'll eat, I'll eat, I'll eat. I have more cookies, does that count?
More cookies. I had cookies. I kind of ate them before I started, so I only have one left.
I don't have, no, no, eat actual food.
Fine, fine, alright, I'll eat something, I promise. I promise, I promise.
Yes, I pinky promise, I pinky swear.
You guys don't want your astronomy? Please don't, no!
My bag, my bag, my bag. Please stop. I don't do it.
It's not worth it. It's not, I swear, it's not worth it.
Yes, after a stream, I'll eat a proper meal.
Am I too close? Let me back up. E.
Money, money, close.
If you pass out, we're going to be upsetty spaghetti.
No, I won, I promise, I promise, I'll be fine. I've been drinking lots of water.
Aren't you proud of me? Water.
I have a fan on, so let me know if the fan is bothering the mic, okay?
Thank you. This is the first fan I've ever had. I've never had a fan before.
I've had an AC, but that broke, so I don't have AC. It's currently still in my window, broken.
It doesn't work. I used to hate it so much, because every time I turned on the AC, it would like literally turn off my power.
I'm not used to my own alert.
Water is important. Yes, I'm migrating.
And they're fine, they're my fans now. Yay! And I appreciate every last one of you.
Thank you so much for the subscriptions.
Is that what they call them? Subscription? Does that sound weird, or is it just subscribers?
Is subscriptions weird, or is subscribers better?
So subscribe! If you're not subscribed, subscribe!
Smash that like button. Is there still a bell?
And click on that little bell, or something like that. Is it like that?
Yeah, there was a big purge. I had 4k, and then it died.
I came back and I had 2.8k. Wow, that was massive purge. It was a big, big purge.
It's alright, I don't mind. I'm having fun just hanging out with you guys. I don't mind this at all.
I'm actually really procrastinating right now. I'm really scared to play the game.
I'm procrastinating.
Am I good with horror at all? No.
Okay, let's put it this way. There was a game that I played a long time ago.
I played this game. I was suggested to play this game, and I'm not good when it comes to feeling like I'm being chased.
And it got up to that part in the game, and I screamed so hard that I started drooling.
I was screaming nonstop, and I was drooling and screaming and drooling.
I thought it would be fun if I got a heart monitor to track my heart rate.
Because, low and surprised, I didn't mention this yesterday, but I actually have, when I said towards the end of the stream, I said that I take medication.
Yes, one of the medications is actually for my heart.
So that would be really interesting if I got a heart rate monitor.
So I put it on the wishlist.
I'll be okay. Don't worry. Don't worry. I'll be okay. I'll be okay.
That's what the medication is for.
I think I was fighting for her life. I was. I really was, and then I didn't even get past the first part of the game.
And then someone told me that that part of the game was actually the tutorial.
Some time later, it was the tutorial. I haven't even gotten it to the actual game, and I never opened the game again.
The biggest chance is that I'll probably cry.
I'll probably start weeping and crying. And if anything, I'll probably ask one of the gen-mates to help me.
Please, please, someone, anyone come in here and comfort me.
Maybe hopefully one of them will come help in, you know, give me some good old slap on the back, you know.
I know some goats who do that do faint, but I don't know.
I have fainted before, so I think good gods can faint.
Yeah, I'll be super bored.
I'm brave. I'm sure this game isn't that scary. I'm sure it's fine.
I'm sure it's okay, and I'm gonna get right through it and be just fine.
I'm so ready. I'm so ready. I'm so excited to play this game. I'm gonna do amazing things.
That's right.
Well, hello everyone who's just now coming and welcome and hi, hi, hi.
I hope all of you have been well yourselves, yes? You all had a good day. You've all eaten breakfast, lunch or dinner.
Brush your teeth.
Showered.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
That's right. That's right. That's what I call good boys and girls.
Nyeom, nyeom, nyeom, nyeom, nyeom, nyeom, nyeom, nyeom, nyeom, nyeom.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
My God, is that a sword to lay? Yes it is! It's me, a sword to lay.
Okay, the fertility goddess, Apia Lojas, Gen 1, and Dolce.
Why is the first king me streaming a horror game?
I don't know, I thought I like, I wanted to add a little spiciness to it.
You know, to the weak, little spicy.
A little bit of spice.
Because we're gonna be biving the rest of the week, you know, chilling, biving.
I really wanted to say, there was a lot of medication that I was on for my stomach.
Because they found like internal, you know, internal bleeds and stuff.
And some issues with my stomach and yadda yadda yadda erosion, yadda yadda yadda, you know, ulcers, yadda yadda yadda.
All of the whatnot, blah blah blah.
I was on some really heavy medication.
Some butt medication.
And it was really, it was really making me super woozy.
I was being really, really slourish.
It made me tired, really sleepy.
But yay, I just got a notice from my doctor that I don't have to take them anymore.
And the one thing that those medications did to me that I was kind of a little sad and disappointed on,
I was on that medication for about a year, a whole year I was on that medication.
Or like close to a year, not really a whole year.
But I was on that medication for a long time.
But what I couldn't do well on that medication and taking oral medication as well,
because I had to take both for the stomach and butt medication.
A booty, booty medication.
I couldn't drink. I couldn't have alcohol.
I couldn't drink for a whole like almost a year.
I wasn't allowed to drink.
I wasn't allowed to have all the alcohols. I was so sad.
And now, now I'm able to drink again.
Yay! I'm so happy. It's been so long.
Yay!
We're off the land, yay!
We're so lonely, healing, slowly.
I still can't eat certain things or make me go blah, but I'm slowly healing.
Yeah, that means streaming, that means drinking streams are good to go.
Yeah, and I wanted to celebrate a little bit with everything that's happening.
So, I'm probably gonna go do a bit of drinking on the, I think it's the 8th.
I'm probably gonna do a little bit of drinking.
So I might come back for super, I think we're playing in supermarkets and later,
I might be a little a little bit dizzy.
Welcome back.
Little tipsy.
It's me celebrating with my fans, me getting off medication and stuff and all the things that I missed out on.
Celebrate from now, come on!
What's my favorite drink?
My favorite drink is soju. Actually, I like soju a lot.
I'm not keen on the really, how you call it, bitter, bitterness of drinks.
I have an extreme sweet tooth, like a really bad sweet tooth.
So I really like sweet drinks.
So I really like soju.
I drink all the flavors so far, not all, most of all the flavors so far.
I think I like peach a lot, peach and the strawberry, the mango one's pretty good.
I like yogurt as well, it's good.
And green, is it green crepe?
Green crepe?
Yeah, an example.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, crepe soju is really good too.
I think soju has 12% so I think that's pretty a lot.
I don't think that's a little bit.
It's either 6% to 12% so I think that's a little bit.
I also, for regular drinks, I guess my two favorite drinks would be amaretto sour.
And what's the other one sour?
Amaretto sour and jet.
There's another one.
Something, something, other sour?
No, not lemon sour.
Amaretto sour and it kind of looks and tastes like ginger ale.
Samurai sour is green and the other one is like, looks like ginger ale.
I don't know, what?
I can't remember the name.
What's the name?
I can't remember.
No, not whiskey sour.
I really can't remember, I can't remember.
Yeah, there's a berry soju, the strawberry soju.
I actually really don't like beer.
It smells like pee-pee.
Oh, like beer.
My first experience with beer was that it smelled like pee-pee and tasted like mop water.
You ever smelled dirty mop water?
Ever just smelled it?
And you can smell what you taste.
You can taste what you smell, I mean.
I hate beer, me and me too.
Yeah, it's a midori sour.
Amaretto sour and midori sour.
Midori sour is green and amaretto looks like, I mixed it up.
Yeah, amaretto looks like, looks like ginger ale.
Oh my god, I had a brain fart.
Yeah, yeah, I had it mixed up, I had it mixed up.
Midori and amaretto sour.
Those are the two of my favorite sweet drinks I like.
Midori, midori sour and amaretto sour.
I had the midori too mixed up.
Midori is green and amaretto looks like ginger ale.
Dirty mop water is stinky.
Yeah, imagine tasting beer and it tastes like that smell.
That was the first time I ever drunk beer and it was horrible.
I hated it.
I was so bad.
There is some good beer out there, but because of that one experience,
I tend to try to stay away from it.
Do you remember the beer? No, because it was at a bar.
It was at a bar, it was my first, it was in a picture.
And there was like a, like sort of, sort of like a sale, I guess.
So it was like really crowded and you got a picture for like, I think a dollar or something.
I gave you dirt beer.
I was a dirt beer.
It was at a bar, I was a first amaretto.
I had a beer.
It was in a really large picture.
How about non-alcoholic beer?
I don't think I ever had a non-alcoholic beer.
I've had a other beer.
Ah, hi everyone, hi.
Hi Emmy.
What come in?
Hi, hi.
Welcome everyone from Emmy's stream.
How did you all enjoy her stream?
Hi, hi, welcome in.
I, I saw Emmy did an ASMR stream today.
I, did you all enjoy the ASMR from Emmy?
I watched a little bit, I enjoyed it.
How are you doing, Emmy?
Hi Nana.
Hi.
Oh, ouch.
I'm sweaty and stinky.
I need to go shower.
Well, thank you so much for the little bread.
I appreciate it.
Go ahead and wash up so you're not a little stinker.
Nice and clean.
What?
So I hope the vibes meet you all well while you're all in here for now.
After such an amazing ASMR stream.
Sniff, sniff, sniff.
Sniff, sniff.
Yes, we do.
If you guys don't know, I do get 100% of merch sales, so if you guys really want to support me that way, you can indeed buy my merch and I get 100% of the merch.
Thank you for bringing that up, thank you.
I didn't get forgot about that yesterday.
You played this game 3 years ago, it's quite the surreal experience.
Oh god.
I'm so ready.
Should we stop procrastinating and start playing now?
Should we stop procrastinating?
Haha.
What's up?
You really like the design on the pant leg on your merch? Thank you, I'm glad you like it.
I forgot to mention I bought a t-shirt yesterday too.
There's also a t-shirt on there.
A sweater, a sweatpants, a t-shirt, a keychain and a standee.
If you get all of them, you can be even closer to me.
Hold me close to your heart, put me on your keys on your most important object when you're outside.
One of your most important objects.
Haha.
Are we ready? Are we ready?
Are we ready when you are?
Ready when you are?
You should play League on stream, I love League.
Maybe, maybe once in a while, like in a blue moon, I will.
Maybe do a morning stream.
So I have two streams in one day.
One for League and one for another game or something.
I can do that.
If you really, really, really want me to.
But it's not gonna be a comment, they play it on stream.
Yeah.
Isn't the longest I've seen someone chatting.
That goes two hour away before.
Any good anime coming out this season?
I haven't actually looked at the summer season anime yet.
I haven't looked at any trailers yet.
I am not sure.
Maybe when I see a video come out or I get a notification, we can watch it together.
If that's allowed.
Cause I don't think that's allowed.
I really don't mind if you guys fall asleep to my streams.
I do not mind.
It's understandable.
If you find me very relaxing, snoozing and the vibes are that real for you.
Then it's understandable that you'd fall asleep.
If I listen to myself, I probably fall asleep too after doing a little bit of cringing.
Yuck.
I hear myself yuck.
Ew.
Don't get it started on anime.
Someone mentioned Rama One Half yesterday and I didn't see it.
And I ended up seeing it when I was going through comments.
And I was like, someone mentioned Rama One Half!
Oh, I'm sorry.
I love Rama!
My favorite voice actors in Rama One Half.
Sorry, the thought just popped into my head.
Remember this?
I love Rama One Half.
Rama is my favorite voice actor and I really love Ryuga a lot.
Ryuga is one of my favorite characters.
If you ask me who my favorite character is.
In Rama.
I mean, I watched the Inuyasha series.
Like, come on, how can I not like Rama?
Shampoo is your favorite?
I like shampoo too.
I love that her grandma's name is Cologne.
What a combination.
Cologne and shampoo.
Shampoo.
You want a bedtime story later?
Maybe I can read you one after we play a scary game.
Because, you know, we're playing a scary game.
I don't know if we're all too scared.
I might like, soothe you all up.
Shampoo is best girl.
Her OST is my favorite in Inuyasha.
I really, really, really, really, really, really, really, really like her OST.
It's one of my favorites.
Shampoo.
No way.
I didn't.
I don't know what you're talking about.
It was place the entire time.
What?
That's crazy.
No.
No, no, no, no.
It was place the whole time.
What you're talking about?
Swing pace?
What?
I didn't add that.
Well, anyway, it's time to game.
Let's go game.
Let's go game, yeah.
We're gaming.
We're so gaming.
We're so ready.
We're so ready to game.
Are we all so ready?
Yes, time.
It's so time.
I'm so ready.
Let me know if the game sound is really loud.
It's hella loud for me.
It's all loud.
Turn it up for me.
For me, for me, for me.
For me, for me.
For me.
A little loud for you guys too.
Gotcha.
How's this? Is this better or no?
No, it's still even louder for me.
I'm gonna turn it down here.
Is it better?
Better.
Awesome.
Excellent.
Let's add some ambience.
Yeah.
Ambience.
Is my head too big?
Am I too big?
Am I in the way?
Am I massive?
Am I too small?
I'll be doing Vans here.
It's on.
Let me turn that off.
It's too small.
No.
I'm ready.
I'm so ready to game.
I'm so ready.
I'm so excited.
Oh, yeah.
I'm so very excited.
Cannot wait.
Wow.
I'm so excited.
Can't wait.
My heart is already hurting.
I don't like the music.
I don't like it. Can I turn it down?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm ready.
Let's do this.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
A place forbidden, everyone.
A place forbidden.
I honestly don't really know much about the game.
This story is a help.
Isn't my apartment?
Then what are we doing in it?
If it's in your apartment?
I definitely didn't fall asleep in this chair.
Okay.
It's kind of spooky.
Uh...
What's that?
What is this?
A book for ants?
Is there a way to run?
Do you only walk slow?
Yeah.
Pretty depressing.
Um...
Oh, I...
I...
Okay. We're fine.
I was...
I was scared.
Okay.
I can do this.
I'm the one that wanted to do this.
I...
I'm fine. Everything's fine.
Everything's fine.
Okay.
Visitors.
Intel Kremlin.
Crewman.
April 9th, 1886.
Mason Thompson, January 5th, 1881.
Leonel.
House.
In 1900.
Ella.
Nams.
Alice.
Samuel D.
Samuel D. Jackson.
Hounds.
Groin.
Bernard White.
Greetings for your visitor.
There are more than welcome to sign your name and a date of your visit in this class book.
Once you've done that,
we welcome you to explore the library to your heart's content
as long as it isn't after closing.
Once you've had your fill,
please let yourself out.
We'll find a key to the front door
on one of the desks in the study.
Oh, God.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
What's in here?
Okay, it doesn't look like it's plugged in.
Unresponsive.
The mouse on the floor.
Oh.
Dad.
Come on, baby.
My other notes are scaring me.
Okay.
What?
The book just moved?
All right.
I'm scared.
Greetings, visitor.
We'd like to take a moment to tell you about
our car extender,
car extender,
warranty.
Our wonderful library.
A library of
books as a state
of the art facility.
The signs
replicate the rural charm found
in many older
buildings without associated risks.
Such buildings are
known and accumulate.
The building might
seem like a strange sight
among wall streets.
Many towering skyscrapers.
But we believe
this dichotomy
will be
what sets us apart.
We're glad you've decided
to give us a chance
and hope that our stock
of books will appeal to you.
Obviously,
our collection of information isn't so vast
as to encapsulate
the whole of the internet.
But we hope
that the charming aesthetic
design of our library
will help
you escape
from the hustle and bustle
of New York life.
If you hear
any strange footsteps,
don't worry.
There may still be construction going on above
or below you.
From us all.
Thanks again.
Footsteps?
Footsteps.
Okay.
Oh boy.
This is fine.
Is this a different one?
Welcome message
from all of our staff. Welcome.
Are you guys okay with me reading everything?
Are you okay with me reading everything?
I'm sorry.
I can read all the transcripts.
It is a nice line.
It would be great.
I'm...
There it is.
I'm glad, I'm glad.
Okay, okay.
Welcome message from all of our staff.
Welcome.
glad you're here. The library is located in picture kit picture key picture key picturesquee picturesquee
the heck how is that a word picturesquee picturesquee picturesquee picturesquee picturesquee
huh picturesquee okay okay okay now i know picturesquee part of britain atop a grassy
mall east of success success success success many rural townships absolutely bereft of their own
libraries refer their villagers to the library as beloved by all produced our vast stop of fiction
long fiction poetry and everything in between chat with friendly librarians and employees
and feel free to spend as long as you'd like reading using your computers or like spending time here
we always love new visitors should you hear any odd knocking in the corners of the building
pay no mind the library is on the other older side and the foundation plays tricks on some
better visitors minds don't worry though it's perfectly safe no bra i don't believe them
i don't believe it not one bit as i remember i was sitting at home reading a letter a strange
thing and i remember what i was all about so fast i can't read that fast i also don't remember putting
anything in my pocket but i feel something all this paper here um room one you should really
clean this place up don't lose the trash room two this room makes me wish i had someone to vent to
and three you can crackling under the strain at the strangest inclination to walk straight into a wall
uh room four there's a secret path in the dark room five i can be really illuminating
the tick fills up on blood
a postal pulses on a dead dog's eye like these your head shall burst like these your head
bro this is this is really intense for me for me i'm sure you guys are fine but holy moly
no bro no bro
no
you
doesn't move at all feels like a warm the phone right here
hello welcome to the library of our robberos we're glad that you've decided to visit our humble
institution hopefully you'll find what it is you're looking for please be informed that the library
is closing since most of our staff are currently away please lock the door on the way out we hope
you've enjoyed your visit i'm not i'm scared is this like a one of those like infinite like
room things i'm actually really scared of those
that dragon
trash on the floor clean up clean up the trash
three trash
uh
a long list of books and dates were checked out funny none of them have the year listed
only months and days
talk about a blast from the past all of the photo numbers
are three digits sure
You can crouch, why would you need to crouch, why would you need to crouch, why would you
need to crouch, why would you need to crouch, why would you need to crouch, why would you
I need to find the right key.
We know you've traveled far to arrive here, so please do rest, keep an open mind, read your heart's content, and we'll be sure you're well provided for.
One matter note, we ask you not to linger after closing, or to descend too far into the library's vows. Some of our books are quite old and very sensitive to the increase of foreign temperatures and washers.
Thank you for understanding.
Weird, almost all of the words will cross out, and the pages are stuck together. I can't open this any further.
A boros, a circular symbol, a snake swallowing its tail, a representation of the endless cycle of death and rebirth,
of wholeness, the infinite, and certain kind of no, this is, this is, this is one of those games. This is one of those games where it's like infinite, infinite rooms, where you go in a circle.
Oh no, what have I got myself into? Oh no, this is one of those games.
Oh, don't go. Oh, oh, don't go.
Oh, and the certain kind of kawaii meaninglessness never puts much stock and mysticism, but in this place it's past pasted all over the goddamn walls.
Though to avoid that, last I remember, I was on some occult's website, sitting on the farthest end of the internet, past the places that normally dissuade the less curious.
I had just a little too much time in my hands, I remember falling asleep. Now I'm here. No recording said that this place is the library of a borough. Or ro boros. Remember reading something about that, but not what or where.
If you're reading this, keep an eye out. Something isn't right. That's the last person who signed the library. It was V.
Oh, it's the flies. I got scared for a second.
Rest the brass. Rest the brass for the key. Rest the brass. Thanks for visiting Arba. Thanks for visiting. Thanks for visiting. Thanks for coming. You can go now.
Can I just go? Can I just leave?
How did the mug get all the hair? Wasn't it on the desk?
Is it okay to leave? I'm just gonna go.
This can't be right. Oh god. Oh god.
The game. The game. The game it crashed.
It crashed. I hear it's back or back.
Hello. We'd like to inform you that the library is now closed. Note that it is unlawful to remain on the premises after closing. This is your one and only warning.
I'm so terrified right now. I'm so sorry.
I'm so scared.
I don't know why I'm cleaning.
Am I stress cleaning right now?
Am I stress cleaning?
Oh, man.
Oh, this is so scary.
So, Mr. Storm, Act 3, Scene 2, Bernice enters while closely by the librarian...
I'm, like, stuttering and everything.
Oh, my gosh.
The librarian, Bernice's breathless, looking both exasperated and slightly excited.
The librarian's expression is unreadable.
As per usual, Bernice, but my husband will find out about us.
Wow.
He won't stay out forever.
Librarian, I wouldn't be so sure, my dear, but shall we retire to the living room
if we're to speak of such unpleasantness as your husband?
Yee.
Bernice's face breaks suddenly into a grin.
She grabs the librarian's hand, taking him onto the couch beside her.
Bernice, I'm fine.
Then if you are to stay, I want to hear some of those secrets you keep talking about.
You can't play with me for the fool forever.
Librarian, I would never claim to do such a thing, my dear.
Would you care to hear how I can stop a human heart with but a word?
Oh.
Oh, Bernice.
Goodness, that sounds dangerous.
Librarian, it most certainly is.
I wish to hear it.
Then, of course, you shall.
He leans close to Bernice, closes her eyes as if expecting a kiss.
The librarian leans past her, whispering something into her ear.
Bernice's eyes open wide.
She gives a single jerk, a strangled groan, and goes limp, sliding off the couch.
Eh? Eh?
Too curious for her own good.
What? What he do? What he do? What he say?
He stands, reaching in one of his pockets to withdraw a single black case containing Bernice's wedding ring.
Taking a cur-cur-cur-curusary?
Curious? Curusary?
Cursory? Cursory look around the living room.
I've never seen that word before.
The librarian eventually focuses on a single point on the opposite side.
The librarian crosses the floor, leaves his item, and turns to leave as he does so the scene darkens,
leaving only a single spotlight to eliminate the stage.
It is fixed on the small black case, which the librarian has decided to leave, sitting on top of the minister's writing desk.
What happened? What he do to her?
He murdered her? Is she dead?
Is she dead?
Very early into my profession.
Professorship? Professorship? Is that a word?
Professorship?
A student came to my office one spring afternoon with a stack of papers in her arms.
She said, she'd be having strange dreams of a place stretching forward and backwards into infinity,
dreams of hallways splitting to hallways, dreams of being lost in the incarnate cuts of some gigantic place that could not possibly exist.
On the papers were crude scratches.
She was no artist, she said, but something about the dreams had left some vivid impression on her that putting what was in her brain on the page seemed her only option.
She was clearly distressed.
When I was gently suggested, when I gently just suggested that she visited the university psychologist rather than the resident,
ancient history professor, she violently shook her head asking if I knew anything about something called an oral boroughs library,
or perhaps a library of oral boroughs.
It wasn't entirely clear.
I told her the common knowledge about the symbol taken from the Egyptians by the Greeks and from the Greeks by the Middle Europeans,
a sign in alchemy of death and rebirth and so forth.
The students continued shaking her head all through my explanation until she suddenly cut me off.
Oh, this one's long.
Those are too old, she said.
The place from my dreams was modern.
It was electricity, computers, but everything seemed ancient and stink of old dust, damped wood and something else.
Please, don't you know of anything in recent times that might have stemmed from that idea?
I confessed, but I hadn't, especially considering the size and the many niches of the modern world.
She left without another word. They were her drawings by and something about the conversation shook me.
I looked through the crude drawings made in a shaky hand and saw in the familiar shapes design an odd air of ominousness.
Ominousness.
I'm a little bit dyslexic, so I hope you guys can understand.
Oh my god.
English is so hard.
It's like ominousness, like looking at the facade of a dark building and hearing the slightest stretching and things that shouldn't be just behind the stones.
All very juvenile thoughts, and yet when I went home that evening, I brought the drawings. I can help but want to look more into what we discuss into that library of arboreals.
It was largely fruitless. I found many sites and articles on alchemy, the symbol itself, or the public library in Obros, county, which was located somewhere in the rural Wisconsin.
But just as the hour crept past midnight, I found something, the slight snatch of information at the bottom of a rabbit hole series of links.
I will not repeat the website's domain or my steps to arrive there for fear that someone might try to replicate what I did.
But I will repeat what I found, because just as that student couldn't get the ideas from her head without drawing, I find I can't think of anything else, waking or sleeping.
I hope those will help. The library of arboreals, a kind of waking nightmare, arrived upon by those too curious for their own good.
Rich in the black secrets, rich in the dark ideas lost to time, rich in languages from dead races on other planets.
The fortunate die. The truly lucky, or perhaps the most unfortunate of all, become tenders for all time, knowing far more than any living being could ever hope to learn without becoming a permanent,
prematurely screaming stain on the face of space's time forever.
This is so scary. Why is reading this even more scary than actually playing the game?
Though we are actually playing the game. There's a lot of reading, and I don't mind it.
It helps me distract myself from the game itself.
None have left. It's unscathed.
There are forbidden tunes on that will that would prevent you from breathing, so to merely touch them, and the tenders are beyond sanity and jealously kept their terrible secrets.
We've searched enough, and this is your final warning.
That night I slept fitfully, my dreams beset by images of dark, dusty plays eerie for its supposed normalcy.
I could almost feel things passing by, just beneath the floorboards within the walls, watching me.
Every exit led to another room, nearly the same as the one before it, and out the window I saw only black.
My dreams have been consistently disturbed since that night, so much so that it is hard for me to teach, so heavily preoccupied is my waking mind.
Waking mind, I hope this writing will be enough for my mind to use one last thing.
I've since tried to find the student who first contacted me to tell her what I learned.
My hope was that I might be able to put her mind at ease, or at least commiserate with her.
But I haven't been able to find her.
In fact, since the day she visited my office, her roommates haven't seen her, nor has anyone else.
And I fear I might be next.
I'm so scared to turn around.
It's so scary to turn around.
The note is largely obscured by blood. You can make out only a handful of words.
And one of the dustier books fell apart in my hands. There were these arcane scribbles, feels. I've tried to read away, but it's still not quite right.
Like something watching.
The vent bolted in pretty tight. I don't see myself tearing this out with bare hands anytime soon.
What's that? More garbage? More trash?
I don't know, I feel this urge to clean, like it will make everything better.
I gotta be less scared if I just clean.
It's locked.
Oh no, I missed the garbage can.
Can I not pick that up?
What the fuck is?
What is that?
Am I okay?
Is this a screwdriver?
If I like get cookies, if I like clean up the library?
It's gone! It's gone, it's gone.
No, no no, no.
No. No. No. No. No, no. No. No. No, no, no. No. No. No. Carine. No. No. No. It's just
shy. Oh no, no, no. A kind slumber. I've been driving for miles and miles and miles
at night I'm scared so tired been on the road for what feels like days don't
like this constant moving never have but yeah it wasn't this bad when I was
younger could sleep in the car while my parents drove I used to do that too and
somehow always knew when I was home wake up like huh I'm home now I don't have
anybody to drive me two of them got too caught up in some of the dark at her
parts of our world a black library borrow old house they went in never came
out there they're why I can't sleep their book what I learned without trying as I
opened the dusty thing sitting disguised disused as I cleaned out what
remained of the attic didn't even mean to and yet here we are they have they are
have they are of their their of their of their of their of a bin sorry there
have been no other cars for hours
this dark stretch of road my truck all I've known as I drive along a hollow a
halo of red and blue neon form and my windshield at best young and the dark a
tiny diner
I'm not hungry I'm not thirsty me neither wait I'm actually thirsty now I'm
hungry too yeah I'm both yeah yeah yeah just tired well the same I take the
exit as it comes up pulling into the parking lot between a beat up Jalopy
Jalopy it's a Jalopy and a truck that looks a lot like my Jalopy Jalopy Jalopy
Jalopy Jalopy Jalopy Jalopy I hardly feel the cold outside I hardly feel any
game and and in the enemy of it
the tongue twister feel anything it's like being trapped and somebody else's
body and things don't feel like they fit right on my muscles anymore the
liners just as cold to stay outside door oh outdoors and hardly more inviting
the distressed red leather of a bunch of boots and that should have been trust
years ago dirty tables floors buffed into a mockery of cleanliness empty but for a
man in a heavy coat in one corner in a waitress the other the man is standing
the waitress is also standing they look like prize fighters about to square off
or wood if they were looking at each other instead I can't see the man's face
first collar and hat and the woman is looking at me no thank you please look
away
seat sir my heart is like my heart is going right now and all we've been doing is
reading I swear that while reading everything feels so more and much more
intense so very very very very intense
seat sir I nod rough weather out she says trying to smile as I take my seat I
can tell it looks terrible do you know a place where I can get some shut up
I asked almost without realizing it I can't sleep but maybe I can still try not
a motel for miles you can sleep at your table if you want though you don't even
have to order anything thank you I sit my head down table my eyes don't shut that
black knowledge slithered it's away from those stained pages and into my brain
and now it grips my eyelids forcing them wide the diner sideways I'm like this
for a few minutes then there is someone else standing sideways in front of me that man
in that coat his face is a dark red mass sleep deprivation tired buddy I nod the
table is cold against my numb face my light literally just flickered and it scared me
oh boy oh boy let's go I'm so excited this is great
okay
I think we can help each other he reaches towards my face laying a hand upon my cheek
there's a flicker of feeling of warm thing that cuts through the fog that's
wallowed up my head for days as he withdraws his hand I see a strip of ragged
flesh in it which he brings to his face when he lifts his hand again the flesh is gone
that he's take his face and he's take his fucking face he take his face
well thanks buddy man thanks for the face thanks so much
thanks delicious faces
may I take the rest may I take the rest
the rest of his face he just nod hi nod the table is cold against my face and as
I finish nodding he turns my head roughly and grabs at it pulling away another strip
of red there's feeling the tiredness becomes more pronounced he doesn't ask
anymore just takes each time his hands come down a little part of me leaves but
at that point I don't care I don't I don't much care take it all I'd like to
rest the table has turned red like the seats around us oh my god oh oh time
passes feelings gone sleep the man in the coat takes down his collar and I see
my face looking down at me tired he reaches down into my pocket fishes out
my keys rest easy buddy he says something else but I don't hear he's gone it all
is let's get it turned around let's get a
little book okay we're fine we're fine we're fine should I throw away trash am I
supposed to be throwing away trash I missed the trash can in the back of the
car bench I hope they don't mind oh she can run can't run near there's no running
huh
I was locked it gives a little and I push on it need some later more power I can't
help but feel as if I stand before the precipice precipice precipice of some
terrible reality left one room only to come right back to it shame there's no
place to go the straight ahead I've had enough few tools in this room I guess the
path ahead isn't what I hope it is if they're not here anymore then good news
I don't know what happened hang on
I think this is broken
I
Deal
Hello
Um, I think, I think that was a broken.
Give me one second.
Technical difficulties.
Alright, I'm gonna be right back.
Give me one second, alright?
Can I fix this?
Give me one second.
You're not you when you're hungry.
Well apparently my doctor told me that caffeine is really good for putting people with ADHD to sleep
and helping them like focus for like a small bit but usually instead of a crash you get tired
and this is more common with people with ADHD so I was recommended to drink a lot of caffeine
so I have well I have I have red bull I have some caffeine tea or is it yeah I've
caffeinated tea and coffee have a lot of caffeine stuff
blueberry red bull the heck is that that sounds horrible
it goes hard down now I have to try it down it only took one person to say it tastes good
I thought everyone was gonna be like yeah yeah don't drink that now I have to try it
the snuggers is so sticky oh it's so sticky
I just like sticking to the top of my mouth
yeah
I'm a snickers almond snickers I like them all my favorite ones
hmm
the heck
me too I like almond don't this kind not actually a big fan of chocolate though
like don't get me wrong I like chocolate my favorite kind of chocolate is milk chocolate
but I don't like dark chocolate at all I really don't like bitter things
I'm a quietist I hear dark chocolate is healthy for healthier for your skin
though I tried it to eat dark chocolate there's only so many brands I can eat
and too much chocolate on my some of my foods is a bit much my favorite flavors
are strawberry and vanilla so if especially if it's ice cream related strawberry and vanilla
I do like chocolate ice cream I do sometimes I hate it but I wouldn't it wouldn't be my go-to
cacao yeah I like cacao I like white chocolate too it's good
should we should we keep trying to play the game I do you think it will crash again
yeah the story was getting good no
one more go
sounds risky
could be I really don't know what the true cause is but we're gonna do some checks after after
everything's fine
we'll do better checking after
we stay smacking
you just want to hear me
very risky
hmm
could always read some books true true you're not wrong I like that idea
how was the game it was it was actually getting pretty good the story was getting
really good it was getting really scary and intense
it's getting pretty a ton
maybe we can continue it another day
how do you guys like that again after figuring out what what went wrong we can't try playing it
another day
yeah some good some good I'm sure some good to me I sounds great love to see more
oh you're all so good when you're all in unison
so cute
yeah it was getting pretty intense
fun fact goats were one of the first animals to be tamed by animals and were being hurt in
9,000 years ago yeah but was it not longer was it only 9,000 years ago
interesting
it's a good fun fact
hmm
yeah you are heard you're all heard
precious little goats
my little bleeding heart
bleep bleep
my little bleep
bleep
yeah we're back a little grassy
I don't know if it's the one with her
even if you're falling asleep have a good night alright
I appreciate you for stopping by
in the stream
have a good night sweet ones
you
humans tamed goat you tamed humans circle of life so be in the circle of life
I have two more chocolates but I don't want to eat them
oh too much chocolate is gonna make me a little sickie
love sugar
thanks for a stream goodnight why is everyone saying goodnight
thanks for a stream thanks for a stream
I'm not going anywhere
I
I'm so funny
no
I saw a few people in chat say they were eepy so I said it's okay for them to sleep and I said goodnight to them
oh no
oh you misheard me it's okay
I see you're a little distracted but that's okay a little distracted can hear my words
heard mine like a hive mind but heard
that was so funny
it's because I'm way too relaxing I can see it
let me move to the room okay let's take this to the bedroom alright
hang on
rawr
I like my BGM alien isn't it
it's very relaxing
rawr
no chaos here only good vibes only good vibes
have you heard that they are making with a squad it's a guy anime I did I did
hear that and I saw a trailer for it and it looks amazing actually curious to
watch it a lot of people have have a not so nice opinion on it and I don't know if
that trailer was actually real I don't know if the trailer was truly true true I
didn't really look much into it I just randomly saw the trailer on putter I
know that's a trailer oh that's cool and then I moved on I didn't really look
into it I thought it was fake I thought it was fake
meow
my chat keeps freezing kind of sad
rawr
the mommy is the mommy is I don't mind just sitting here hanging out with you guys
for a little bit I don't mind that
um no
I have a story that I can read you guys and you guys really want you know ready to
go story still
I
want a story
I can read you
I'm gonna fall asleep on me aren't you
the pretty long one pretty long story
I hope you don't mind
do you have any ghost stories no I don't think so
I found a random story
that's really long it's called the
it's called the hunter's wife it's a short story
the
ouch
mommy's dangerous
that's a fast out well it's supposed to get more dangerous when I read the story
wait why are you eating chocolate are you lactose and and
and
you think do you think a little bit of lactose stops me
not gonna stop me I do what I want I do what I want
I do not want
ah
I'm down
hi
I
should never learn that's right what is there to learn
I'm going to pronounce words wrong I'm going to say things wrong
I'm going to see I'm going to read things wrong and then I'll do it again and I'll do it again
and I'm do it again and again and again and again and again
are you gonna correct me and I'm gonna do it again
I don't mind you guys correcting me but we're gonna have to understand that even if you
correct me the chances of me saying it wrong again are 99.99% high 99.99% high
you're just gonna get that from me I really gonna have to deal with that
making tea you want some right now I do I don't want some tea sounds amazing I
have more cookies I can make tea mistake I'm actually having my stuff
we're fine we're fine we're fine everything's fine
rumbling I wish you only stopped at rumbling it's like twisties your is
tummy ever hurts to the point where you get the twisties like us like it feels
like something's pinching your stomach and then twisting grabbing quite a big
bunch and twisting not like small pinch but like a you grab a lot of skin you
know you grab a lot of it and then you twist it that's that's what I feel when
I get the tummy eggs
it's okay if you missed a stream or two that's fine you can always go back and
watch the vod they shouldn't be going anywhere so if YouTube comes and goes and
then I don't know what to tell you I do need to eat food it's true
I'm during my next my next page act and I'll get food I promise alright next
page act food I'll get it I promise I promise I promise I promise
hmm
I pinky promise hmm
Remember your pinky promise?
It's a food sooner than that.
I can eat some bread.
I like bread.
I eat some bread.
You put the apple on it.
95% pinky.
Don't make the promise.
Pull pink.
Pinkie, pinkie, pinkie, pinkie, pinkie, from love.
I'm very rubbing my own tummy.
I don't like tummy.
It doesn't really help.
Not all the time.
Cookies, chocolate, bread bowl.
That's what I'm going to eat today.
It's the best meal.
The only meal I eat today.
Cookies, chocolate, and bread bowl.
I'm going to eat some bread.
My finger.
I have a lot of bread bowl and water.
I have to drink water because my kidney has been having issues lately.
I have tons of water.
What's 24?
24.
I'm doing math.
48.
48 water is sitting right here next to me.
I drunk all 24 in the span of a week.
I have a ton of water next to me.
Water is very important in my diet.
Basically a four course meal.
It's true.
Alright, mama's okay.
I'm going to put anything between the bread to make a sandwich.
I have male nails.
I can't have male nails that make my stomach hurt.
It makes me go bleh at the same time.
I can't eat male nails.
Have you ever been like, this is a poor person's story.
I've ever been so broke.
What was your brokeest food you ever ate?
Mine was bread and mayo.
I would take mayo, put it on a slice of bread and eat that.
Sleep. Relatable.
So relatable.
I'm so funny.
You see bread mayo because you liked it.
I ended up liking it afterwards.
But it was definitely just broke person food at the time.
It was literally all I could eat.
Where I used to live, we had mice.
So a lot of our food wasn't really good to eat.
We had the big ol' micey micey.
Small, really small, tiny micey micey.
Air.
Jam sandwich.
Spam in the dollar store.
A squid of mustard to get some kick.
Gold Caesar salad, isn't that dangerous?
I heard people got really ill from eating old salad.
Sounds dangerous.
Careful.
I read in sauce and stories, some crazy stories about the most innocent food murdering people.
Potatoes.
You guys heard about the potatoes?
This is getting dark fast.
I actually can't eat ramen.
Packaged ramen.
My stomach can't digest the noodles for some reason.
Processed noodles.
Whatever they're putting in the noodles and packaged ramen, my stomach can't digest it.
So like 5 to 10 minutes after eating it, it comes back up really fast.
It comes all back up right away.
I can have ramen, unfortunately, unless it's freshly made.
Freshly made ramen.
Very very fresh.
I have a favorite ramen spot that I go to.
I can't go often because it's really far away from me.
And I can't really travel far because of my health.
So if I'm feeling really good, I go there.
It's my favorite place.
And I'll eat there because it's homemade.
Scratch. Ramen made out of scratch.
From scratch.
And it's really really good.
When you're so broke, you look for things to smell to fill you up.
Bro!
I get you.
Bro.
I understand.
Bro, I understand it, but I understand you.
Bro, I get you.
Water in Cheerios is crazy!
No!
Water in Cheerios!
Yeah, I can't travel far because of my health.
That is indeed what I said.
So when I feel really really good and I take all my meds and I'm feeling really great,
and I can go far, I do.
And I go even further.
Even further than that.
But I get really tired really fast.
And because the medication I'm on makes me sleepy,
I end up falling asleep in public on public transportation and stuff.
So I go.
I get really really really exhausted easy and then my back starts hurting,
my legs and my arms.
And I'm like, I gotta sit down.
I have to sit down.
I can't walk anymore.
So I end up like sitting and stuff.
I have to...
I have to sit down.
My little brothers are like,
ah, two guys talking about how poor they were growing up.
We ate the fruit off the wallpaper.
No way!
And I'm mad, I know what fruit wallpaper they're talking about.
How do I know that?
My grandma used to have the...
She used to put wallpaper on her cabinets.
Her cabinets used to have the fruit wallpaper,
usually on the inside, on the floor of it,
or like somewhere in the kitchen.
When grandma comes,
rum rum.
Hope I'll be less broke now.
Me too.
And then I'll be able to finally give my own place.
I still live with my family.
There's quite a lot of them here.
This place is really small, very loud.
I can't really do my ASMRs for you guys properly.
So I hope you guys understand about the quality
of some of my ASMRs
and the quality of some of my, uh...
things.
I, uh...
Unfortunately...
I'm sorry.
Voice crack.
Unfortunately, be, uh...
careful when it comes to sounds and stuff.
My chat froze again.
And I think...
I think it's back?
Oh, it's back.
You'll like it your country, huh?
I mean, being my age
and still being, you know, here
makes me feel a little down.
But I understand, given, um...
the generation is smart
to stay with your parents anyways.
But I, I can't...
I cannot take it much longer.
Okay, I have, like, no freedom.
No freedom to do what you want.
Can't even walk around my own...
my, um, the house
or my own room.
Uh, Nicky, a majority of the time.
Can't even do that.
It's not fair.
I have to worry about people just opening my door.
Hello?
Aw, man, come on.
Let me be free.
Nicky.
Does the merch go directly to you
or to Valor, Valor?
Uh, directly to me.
I get 100% a merch.
Directly to me, yeah.
It's, uh, my heart.
Uh, it's doing, uh,
loop-de-loops right now.
It's almost time for me
to take my medication, I believe, I think.
I'm not really paying attention to the time.
I was supposed to be reading you guys a story,
but I'm just fiving here with you guys.
You sure it's not the Red Bull?
I haven't drunk any yet.
I only mentioned that I have Red Bull,
but I haven't drunk any yet.
I have Red Bull yet.
Not yet.
I'm just thinking about it, but not yet.
Please don't go.
I'm not going anywhere yet.
Not yet, not yet.
A lot of yet-yets.
Not yet.
I'll be around for a while.
You're enjoying the chit chat?
You already got your hoodie?
Well, thank you.
I'm glad you could say, where's the hoodie?
Eventually, you'll even get the sweatpants, too, to match.
You was trying to tip on stream elements,
and I won't let you.
I am not really sure
what their issue there is.
Hmm.
Can you have a pat?
Sure you can.
Good boy.
Good girl.
Here you go.
Wanna have a pat too?
Wanna hug, too?
I'll give you a hug.
Hmm.
You like that?
Hmm. Here you go.
Nice hug.
There you go. Nice hug.
Trani said, uh, was saying that some girls had paper restricted because it was coming in so fast.
Most likely, yes, I think that's what I remember as well.
That's probably the case.
Chad is greedy. No, Chad is a cutie.
That's what mommy is here for.
Chad wants hugs. Chad wants cuddles.
Chad wants kisses.
I don't want to get hit by YouTube.
It's gonna be a thing, isn't it? Just hashtag no pants gang.
True. I'm not wearing pants either.
Who wears pants? Who needs pants?
Surely not me.
There's someone who doesn't like it when they don't wear pants.
You're so lucky.
I was just out of space with my own.
No pants, no nothing.
With an AC.
I get it though.
Pants shouldn't even exist. I don't even know why clothes exist.
It's so uncomfy.
Does anyone else get a little overstimulated when they wear clothes?
Like, do you ever get this feeling when clothes rub against your skin?
And it feels like some sort of like burning sensation?
Over-stimulated.
Clothes exist so you won't get banned on YouTube.
True. True.
It's like not really like a burning burning,
not like a real burning, but like a
strange tingling sensation
that gets intensified on your skin
when certain material rubs against your skin
for a really long period of time. It's like an extreme tingling.
I get that.
I get overstimulated so I don't like wearing clothes.
Then I'm gonna rip it off.
Get it off me! Get this off me!
Get it off me!
And sometimes the heat doesn't make it any better.
Imagine being like, imagine getting that tingling feeling
and feeling hot and sweaty.
I hate it.
I love the cold air.
I love cold air.
My favorite season needs to be spring
but because spring doesn't
last very long where I am,
I don't think spring is going to last that long.
Spring lasts very long where I am.
Spring disappears in like a month or two
because spring doesn't last very long. Fall has kind of become
the stand-in since fall does kind of last
a little longer until it starts snowing.
Spring and fall are my favorite seasons.
I really like the smell of flowers
and the plants growing and stuff.
Everything's sprouting. I like it walking by.
What time do I shower at?
At the hottest. Like boiling.
If you were a normal human or to put their hand
in the water, it would burn you.
I shower at excruciatingly hot
hot water. I don't know why but when I feel
lukewarm water on me while I'm showering,
I lose it. I don't know. It's not hot enough. It's not hot enough.
I have to turn it up a little more. It's not hot enough. More. It's not hot enough.
More. And then it goes all the way at the end
and sometimes it's still not hot enough.
I gotta be careful though sometimes because
the play...
Sarah just scared me so bad. It's medication time.
My poor heart.
Let me grow my plants.
They're fine.
But yeah. I gotta be careful sometimes.
The hot water can get excruciatingly hot.
It's never the same temperature every time you use it.
So sometimes I guess the boiler
is doing really good for one night
and
it'd be really bad.
Sometimes it does burn me right away. That's why you gotta start in the center.
You gotta start warm and then turn it up slowly.
Okay.
I don't know where my water went.
I got it.
Yeah.
Sorry about that.
Hard on me to hear that at all.
I can't...
I really don't think
V2P Studio likes me...
I really don't think V2P Studio likes me very much.
very much. Is that asthma medication I hear? It is. It is. I have everything wrong with
me. I check the full bingo book. I did bingo five times.
Hi.
You guys are so cute.
I'm putting on my cream from my spine and my shoulder.
It's all wet.
It's almost super wet.
Wow.
It's so creamy. It's like weird white, like
kind of milky, but it's like kind of clear, but slightly white. Cream looks weird.
It's,
It's
Are you the type to sleep in the cold with a blanket or the type to not wear it and be
woken in the middle of the night?
If it's really cold out I'd wear like three blankets because it gets really really cold here like super super cold
So three blankets, lots and lots of blankets
Honestly it's very... during the year of nurturing a passionate person just by the things you have to deal with
I appreciate that so so very much thank you thank you so much
It's very kind of you to say I I like to think that being positive uh
being staying positive keeps the energy high and keeps you at peace uh at peace of mind when you
know you're uh if you are sad all the time you feel kind of bad a lot of the time so being positive
wanting to keep the vibes high and not wanting to be you know sad all the time really helps
with that so I don't want to be that person so I do my very best when it comes to that
um
Okay, yeah, so I understand being sad though.
It cannot be helped. I have my days too. I'm sure everyone does too,
but they feel absolutely lonely or really sad and down and that's why I resonate with people
like that and I've felt that feeling of extreme loneliness before and I don't like it. So it's
kind of one of the reasons why I wanted to be a vtuber from the very beginning. I always thought
it was something nice, but even before that, just a streamer period, I wanted to
build a community of people who are like me,
people who need a place, people who need someone to talk to, someone to keep them company when
they are down and sad. So I always wanted to be someone like that for other people because I
didn't want no one to ever feel or felt, feel like how I felt in the past. Oh god, I'm such an emotional
person. What's wrong with me? I am like hanging on by a thread.
And it's very, very, very, very, very much okay to be sad. It's okay to feel the way you feel
because it's easier to get through your emotions and understand them so that you feel better
about everything else as long as you understand how you feel and how you are and the way
as an overall and then you'd know and you can move past it. You accept it and you move past it
and there's always going to be some things you can never get over. There are some things I don't
think I could never get over so I understand. It's already been six months since I lost my
fur baby and I think about him every day. I think about him every single day.
Yeah.
I have pictures of him if you guys ever want to see him one day.
I have some pictures and I hold the air.
I can always post them later, later on, okay?
I'm sorry to anyone who has also lost
a friend, not to say a friend or a family because he was my family. It was my friend.
So, baby, I'm going to
I'm probably going to one day ask you guys to show me your pets.
So, I'm prepared. I do love seeing everyone else's pets and it doesn't matter what kind of pet you
have. Cat, dog, goat, horse, pet chickens, spider,
axolotl fishes, any kind of fish, even a dangerous kind.
I love them dearly.
Life is amazing.
I think they're all cute.
They're your little friend. They're cute. I think snakes are really, really cute.
So, yeah, adorable little snoops and then a little tongue-tickle.
I love it.
I used to have a cat that knew how to turn on the faucet.
He really liked water and he would sit in it.
He'd always ask for a bath. I miss him too.
I had quite a lot of pets when I was growing up. I had a big heart for pets. Even had a pet pigeon.
One of my family members saved it during a storm. Its entire nest had fallen.
The others were unfortunately unable to be saved. They saved a little baby pigeon.
The other pet pigeon for a while.
We didn't really get a chance to give it a name because we weren't going to keep it.
This was a long time ago though.
I've had parrots. I've had five cats. I think we had two. We had two cats that we thought one was a
girl but turned out to be a boy. He had a little peepee.
It was a little peepee and we couldn't tell. It was a little peepee.
It was very cute.
He was my favorite. He was my favorite kitty.
We found out. We found out he was a boy when he got older.
Unfortunately we couldn't change his name. He had a name for years and we didn't know.
He had a name for years.
So he had a girly name.
He had a girly name. His name was Mimi.
His name was Mimi.
He had gimme pigs growing up. I knew someone who had a bunch of gimme pigs.
They had so many that they had to leave their apartment door open.
They had to leave it open and put a pin outside the door.
The gimme pigs were massive. They were huge. They had four of them.
I had a tuxedo cat.
We found out it was a male.
He made me feel so used to their name. We couldn't really change it.
They responded to the name. Imagine changing their name
as they got older. They would have been so confused.
It's not my name.
We kept the other people and let them run around the living room every once in a while to get
their exercise done. It's so cute. It's so cute.
I like that. I like that a lot.
Unfortunately, I don't live in a place where we can have outside pets.
I don't live in a place where that's possible.
So they endure, endure only.
A lot of harm outside. Endure, endure only.
I'm sorry. I'm quiet. I'm just reading what you guys are saying.
You guys bring a big smile to my face or hair.
I'm going to undercap the goblin king.
I thought we said jarred.
Don't eat rocks, please.
It's not good for you. It's not good for your tummy.
I had two birds a long time ago named Red and Wilma. That's cute.
Surprisingly, Mimi wasn't a big cat. Mimi looked very feminine.
Even when he got older, he was like the runt of his litter. He was very, very small.
He was tiny. And as he got older, he was extremely small then.
So he looked a lot like a female cat.
All right. I think it's time.
I can read. I was going to read your story, but we were vibing so hard.
And I, myself, am getting really sleepy. We can always save the story for another time.
Yeah, we all forgot, huh? We all forgot about the story.
That's probably going to be a lot of a majority of these streams where we derail quite a lot.
But it's fine if the vibes are right. I don't mind this. It's fun.
I love chatting with you guys and reading what you'll have to say.
That hurt mine.
Yeah, there was supposed to be a story time, but it was decided because of the game
crashing me. But I do want to start getting ready for bed. My medication does make me extremely tired,
so I'm like hanging in there now. My medication makes me really sleepy.
Yeah, I'm on a raid of Mercy. I will go say hi. Let's prepare to raid Mercy.
And then whoever is going to bed, please get rest. Everyone deserves to feel rested and feel good.
Sorry.
Okay, let me make sure I have this.
Oh, dang.
Okay.
Ok.
Marcy is doing killer, killer 7. I think she's playing killer 7. So let's all say hi.
Bleeding Raid. Bleeding Raid. Thank you. I'll miss you. I'll miss you too. I'll see you guys.
Right. So I won't be streaming tomorrow. I'm gonna get some rest. Usually I don't stream
on um yeah for Gorn Raid. Usually I don't stream on Mondays and Tuesdays.
So today was an exception because I have doctor's appointments every week and Monday and Tuesday
are the days that I go to doctors. So and I can try and squeeze streams in on either day
but this is a high chance that I'll have an appointment that I would need to go to.
Usually they're in the noon and then I come I gotta come home and then I can stream
uh right after but because I'm on like heavy medication um I'm usually really tired before
the stream um so yeah there's that and uh I feel like there was something else that I completely
forgot to mention. My brain is not there right now. Oh yeah um I'm sure you guys saw the tags.
I posted our tags on Twitter um I completely forgot about our general tag so everyone got
to get the tags they wanted. So yeah for Gorn is now our like our general tag where you guys can
tag me like if you all want to like just send me something some love uh some like message a nice
message something or tweet or anything you can use hashtag apricorn or anything I do uh say
or blah blah hashtag apricorn. It's a general tag you can use that for like anything anything
and everything um and I'll do live uh you can stay do live for when I go live yeah yeah yeah
it's perfect and our memes tag is still by Azora. That's all yeah
and so everyone please remember about the merch you can click the link and the
file if you really want merch and remember to like and subscribe like and subscribe
and please leave a comment
I don't think I'm used to doing that
I'm so not used to doing that it's so fun and slash that though
yeah
and also if you guys really want to see the spicy audio remember all those links are in the bio
my hand bye bye everyone okay have a good night and or morning or afternoon or evening
bye bye bye
so